bring it in over him
and I'm getting over her the eyes had it
babe and got a c-word that is why
Shelton's candid news song came here to
forget it's already doing very well
number one in the iTunes Country chart
and Blake told me that his new music was
gonna be really personal and boy he was
not kidding in fact the name of his
album which is out May is called honest
and it's pretty clear that he is talking
about Gwen Stefani and both of their
divorces listen to this part looks like
it's juice is through country legend
Dolly Parton is all about sharing her
life and her lyrics so Michelle Turner
got her reaction to Blake's new song and
his new love
I think they look great as a couple and
they've both been through similar things
I met her when I was out there doing the
voice and she seems very sweet and but I
love Miranda also yeah and you know so
it's like I just think all those say you
know what happens in people's lives but
they're all great people I'll just wish
them all the best
well aside from Blake and Gwen dolly has
got one degree of separation from
another Hollywood couple we love dolly
is godmother to Miley now and she's back
with with Liam and it seems like they're
back engaged again she's great she's a
talent she's deep she's smart she's
sensitive and she's gone through a lot
she's been put through a lot and she put
herself through me like them together
yes I do I was really happy to hear that
they had gotten back together
dollie knows about relationships in May
she will celebrate her 50th anniversary
with husband Karl Dean
then in June dolly will start her
60-city pure and simple tour is her
first major tour in 25 years in the best
part she's 70 years old and looks
amazing
go back on tour what is a staple in
Dolly's dressing room
well cough drops water I have to drink
water
gypsum day okay first of all do not come
in here looking like you look and tell
me that you're eating chips and dip well
I used to be a lot heavier I used to
bring oh yes get back in the back in my
early days in country music when I was
eating everything they put my dressing
room
yeah I've gained quite a bit of weight
but any entertainer will tell you
nothing worse in the world then trying
to go out trying to entertain when
you're closer to time you think oh my
belly looks big everybody's looking at
my belly
you